is this real I don't know I have no idea
somebody tweeted at me I thought it was
hilarious so I screenshot at it I
believe it because there was that lady
with the sperm but there's no it was a
lady or I forget who it was on um it was
on a video I did wasn't it the Amazon
video so the Craigslist post about how
she drinks semen smoothies there's that
she yeah she was like looking for she
was looking for someone to come and be
that will come yes she was looking for
someone to come alright I'm just going
to do the so I thought there was a dude
with a channel yep see if you just if
you type drinking sperm into YouTube the
benefits of drinking sperm with drinking
semen sperm is the new superfood 5 tips
to ensure okay that's different oh
that's the is the new superfood that's
so funny
yeah it's crazy if you drink it through
your vagina then you can create life it
really is a superfood and so this
article it says mom of two yeah mom of
two am I'm fighting off coronavirus by
drinking sperm smoothies Jesus do you
think someone will go through through
this amount of effort to fake this it's
a whole [ __ ] article oh no this is
the same lady this is the same lady on
YouTube that I just saw Tracy kiss she's
like making this her brand yeah this is
her thing let's just let's just get a
little sound bite here from Tracy kiss
oh that was a brute was that you what
was that
brutal way to start a YouTube videos and
you may have seen before I did a video
called the semen facial tutorial the
idea behind that I've seen plenty of
videos like that yeah man
lady would be the first time I watched
it okay
semen facial lady um Tracy if I if I may
you're going to have to differentiate a
little bit because you know my
experience with semen facials is you
know it's kind of out there yeah I know
I probably have seen more than you Oh
[Laughter]
trust me lady I don't need a tutorial I
can I know exactly what we're talking
about here I love this I love this frame
right here modeling the bowl is that
yeah that's really funny and then look
at the the close-up of her skin is that
is it shiny because yeah potentially
there's semen on it right there or is
this kind of like the after picture
Tracy leaves the semen on her face for
15 minutes mmm see ladies so don't you
know don't get all bent out of shape
about the towel
it's good for you look look at the sub
title here image-conscious mom Tracy
kiss reveals how her pals semen oh she
friends ona dude and then the friendzone
her husband oh my if you could just come
in a jar for me that'd be great hi
Lachlan yeah I'm here to pick up a job
semen yeah we could but we could both
come we could just do this together and
then we can just take the chance okay ya
know Lachlan I I see you like a brother
you're my pal you're my pal you like the
brother I never had
uh-huh so you would use your brother's
cut yeah it's like family all right
Brent oh my sweet [ __ ] that one is that
one's mean do we have a brain Rivera
video that we can watch today but let's
keep going with this yeah let's see
what's up with this lady clean and
healthy ingredients in audience for my
beauty nowadays you have no idea what's
going into your products that you
purchase in the supermarket the foods
that you eat
there's you know this is a positive
posit if you ask me if you ask me what's
the worst thing that you think would be
in like a product that you buy from CVS
or like something that could be on your
vegetables a year but your produce from
the grocery store I would say come yeah
yeah any kind of come okay that's a
worst-case scenario dog whatever you
name it you don't know it's in there sir
sorry sorry
it's our first bad reactions something
that's very serious
they can live with you for a lifetime so
I was looking into natural remedies
things that you can have from home that
are organic that don't cross the earth
back man man man
what what sir what's your to think the
research process was what do you mean
she was looking into it yeah idea what
what is the is the path there hmm
home remedies for what were you trying
to get a remedy for that took you to
come true actually what are you trying
to solve yeah get a getting pregnant you
know or you know was it it's you know
what it was what she was hooking up with
the dude and she was like where do you
want to put anything on your face she's
like yeah and then he finished and then
he's like okay I'm gonna go to the
bathroom he just never came back and so
she was sitting there with it on her
face she's like what do I do now and he
never went and got her the towel so now
she's trying to remedy how do I get this
off my face what do I do next and in
that process little article goes ah you
know it's good for you but okay that
aside did she read an article and then
someone else has tried this already so
she just like ripping someone [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's what I'm thinking or maybe
she's just sitting there with it on her
face and she's like maybe I don't need
to take it off and that's when you know
she starts doing this she starts doing
this and then she makes a cup of tea
yeah you know with it on yeah and it's
drying mm-hmm just like a face mask does
mm-hmm and then she washes her face and
she's got that like post-sex glow or
something like that yeah and she thinks
it's from the semen and then here comes
her the dude she was hooking up with a
week later out of guilt he brings her a
towel and he goes hey that was rude of
me and I'm sorry I want to present you
with this so you may finally clean me
clean me off of you
she goes oh don't worry
I'm very clean better than clean I got a
hook in here what her [ __ ] thing is
here or logic she delivers the results
that you require parts of the
superficial then led me on to looking
into the benefits of digesting semen
she's saying all this [ __ ] in Jim shark
clothes like we're supposed to just be
focused on the science of the matter
sitting here half-naked talking about
yeah look at the benefits of ingesting
semen is a yeah sure yeah yeah dudes are
sitting there like what about the
benefits of excreting it yeah
and [ __ ] right up so like who's um who's
like do you take donations how can how
can we get involved all 1 million of us
want to know how we can get involved I
wonder if this is actually true I would
like to see some real research on this
besides this just as one chick saying
over and over again that it's good for
you yeah on whether or not actually
drink not that I would do it I just want
to know this is like any any if this is
legit in any way I just you know just if
in case anyone is working on their
thesis has a background in medicine and
you know can verify the positives I
would just like to know I'm just yeah
I'm just simply curious you know not uh
not bicurious you know by any means but
just you know she would have this
[ __ ] dreamcatcher tattoo on her
stomach - yeah I know so what is it go
ahead what does the article say the
article just says she's not worried
about kovat 19 as she thinks her unique
way of keeping healthy will ward it off
though some may find her controversial
method methods hard to swallow
nice that's funny this is really funny
it's like she's like so desperately
trying to make it her brand that she's
just re packaging mm-hmm this little
viral moment mm-hmm it's like the
government repackaging their programs
for crime this is her version yes I tell
the world that I drink semen today she's
part of the problem dude she's part of
this big Overmind that's trying to get
us to drink our own sperm they're trying
to get us to stop reproducing and
consume our sperm this is a real
conspiracy yeah they're trying to get us
to stop reproducing through to porn
mm-hmm boom people this is oil hats on
yeah this is this is some [ __ ] honestly
Ted however many years later she's
getting she's gettin playoff this good
for her yeah you know hustle is hustle
you know yeah she wants if she thinks
that one day she's gonna monetize this
and she's gonna sell her own branded
semen yeah I mean juices or whatever I
mean
Gweneth Paltrow sold the vagina candle
yeah
that's a good point I have oh I want to
know what that [ __ ] smells like some
piece I remember some people bought it
and did reviews on it I never watched
any did you ever I think I watched
criticals review of it and I remember I
fast-forwarded like right to the part
where he says what it's actually smells
like cuz I was like I want to know does
it actually smell like that but I don't
think it does no I mean no it's gonna
smell like something fake like flowers
it's like the essence of like what it
smells like what a vagina looks like or
whatever oh yeah okay you know what I'm
saying yeah I would love to you know we
should do bro we should make our own
candles and we actually try to create
the actual scent of ballsack after a
full workday hmm
and call it what cheese
[Laughter]
you